despite being one of the largest oil
producers in Africa Nigeria went through
yet another fuel crisis in early
December
at times the price increased 300 percent
instead of using a bus or taxi Alex
Gabriel uses the cheapest mode of
Transport he can find from here to my
destination initially was 15 error but
now we ain't 100 115 150 so the
economies
so the economy now is dealing harshly on
us it is very very harsh on us
at all
this one is very very stressful even we
don't even have there is no place to buy
there is no place to buy four so most of
these committers they just
take that as advantage to extort from
people
the government subsidy program is meant
to make feel more affordable
but critics say it's corrupt and oil
suppliers say they've not been paid in
months many people here say the cost of
traveling to and from work is far higher
than what they earn the high cost of
fuel not only impacts the cost of
Transportation but almost all aspects of
daily life
Christie akinlunu buys groceries at this
Abuja Market several times a week
expensive most people can even afford to
even buy Christmas rice now for example
things have gone up and they are very
expensive and they're very unbearable
too so it's it's something funny it's
something funny lately it's been tough
she's not the only one surprised by the
rising prices
right now the prices are not friendly
because I got apples I usually buy
apples for 100 naira which is one apple
hundred naira I just came to the market
today and they're telling me Apple is 3
500 I'm like how the lady was like
that's how the price of things are so
I'm forced to buy it
scientists have warned that if nothing
is done to combat climate change things
will only get worse the floor that they
sell was very high due to the flooding
many farmer cannot go into production
and due to the scarcity of production
you find out that we have little
resources to feed the demand the supply
was so very small that the demand cannot
afford to purchase in the open market
fighting between the military and armed
groups in farming areas is also
affecting Food Supplies High government
debt and Rising inflation is putting the
economy under pressure and as Nigeria
heads to the polls in a couple of months
a worsening economy is likely to
influence how people vote famida Miller
Al Jazeera Abuja